now let's get into that first story from
the daily mail
bad news twitter says it will not
reinstate trump despite elon musk vowing
significant change to woke platform
after taking a board seat with nine
percent stake but this also means
it's there's to be no alex jones no milo
yiannopoulos twitter said it has no
plans to reverse any policy decisions
and it's com and is committed to
impartiality in the development and
enforcement of its policies and rules
now that being said
okay they say our policy decisions are
not determined by the board of board or
shareholders and we have no plans to
reverse any policy decisions as always
our board plays an important advisory
and feedback role across the entirety of
our service our day-to-day operations
and decisions are made by twitter
management and its employees
they can say that
but i'm not entirely convinced because i
do think with a 9.2 percent share elon
musk has substantial weight
a lot of people are pointing out that i
can't remember the guy's name someone
they said someone was it ryan cohen
he bought a stake in in game stop and
then got a position on the board or
something like that i'm not entirely
sure but uh people are saying look even
though it's not a controlling share it's
not 50
it scared them enough to give elon what
he wanted in terms of a seat at the
table and part of that arrangement with
elon says he can't buy in any way more
than 14.9 percent of the company so i
think they're scared of a pump and dump
i think they're scared he's gonna get
too much power and i think
elon might actually have uh an impact on
this platform at the very least if they
listen to what the man has to say he's
going to make all of them much more
wealthy and if they don't well then they
can i mean the dudes
whatever he's touching is turning to
gold right with tesla spacex and all
that stuff yeah he's doing a great job
with all that all those things but but
uh
where does it even where does this go
and and i got i got to say
everyone's really excited about elon
buying a portion of the company then
this morning we hear that elon is on the
board of directors does anyone really
believe there's going to be substantial
substantial changes to this platform i
think everyone was looking for something
a little hopeful i think people want
things to be better on twitter where you
can
say true things and not be banned for it
um i don't know that elon musk is going
to provide that kind of change that he
would have the power to do so um i think
like a what is it like morgan stanley
also owns 9.2 percent is it nine point
two i think no no no i think he's the
largest he is the largest are you sure
because i was looking at it the other
day and they had a 9.2 share so
blackrock owned something like
6.2 7.2 i could be wrong i don't know i
mean i did it last night i took a look
at it but i don't know how to find it
fast but yeah i know that um but they
haven't they probably haven't affected
any substantial change um but elon musk
obviously
made this buy in order to affect change
i like elon musk so that's the question
is does he have the power to do it does
he have the wherewithal to do will he be
allowed to do it three billion dollar
2.89 billion dollar purchase to make
this move you know i like elon musk i
don't know if anything good is going
gonna happen from this but boy is is
everything just so boring he's also had
a lot of back and forth on the platform
with jack dorsey which i think has been
so interesting because dorsey the other
day apologized
that was really interesting i think his
perspective um dorsey has two percent
2.25 right two i don't know i had i
thought it was two
but uh you know but look look look it's
interesting when trump was in office and
when trump was on twitter it was like
being on a roller coaster every day
it was fun right and now that he's gone
it's just like every day it's like oh
look and you know they bombed somebody
again and so elon musk comes in and he's
like i'm gonna make this ridiculous
three billion dollar purchase and i'm
like all right something's happening i
gotta hold it like something happens i
got a lot of thoughts on this i hope
this isn't just an expensive way to make
sure that he doesn't get banned off the
platform
as long as i have almost 10 stake
they're definitely not going to ban me
off the platform but i have a lot of
thoughts on this because as we're seeing
different social media platforms emerge
and then others become old and kind of
useless i'm not sure that same thing
will happen with twitter i see some of
these old social media companies try to
stay relevant one way or another
facebook by buying instagram and doing
their new meta thing but now we're kind
of seeing how tick tock kind of took
them all over very quickly but at the
same time ambivalent because as you guys
know trump just started truth social and
that fell flat on its face so if there's
no way which way to go and while he
might be a better alternative than say
jack dorsey or perrog
the currency
he's not going to be a ceo yeah but it's
he'll be like that influence will be
good there but also i think we need to
be critical of elon musk i'm extremely
hawkish when it comes to china and they
just opened a bunch of factories in
china and many companies in china are at
the whim of the chinese government and
he's praised them he's praised them also
like awkwardly as well because he also
praises american values too so i don't
know if he's a businessman just trying
to play into both sides also 10 cent a
chinese company has a 5 stake in tesla
so there's a lot of different loans and
influence there something to keep an eye
on but better than the alternative the
thing with truth social is it didn't
offer anything new to the concept of
social media it didn't even offer trump
well it didn't even offer trump yeah
what am i going to sign up for what's
the point like yeah the point of truth
social was to try to sign up and see
what trump says and i still just get his
little statements in my email but that's
the thing about the new social media
platforms right getter and truth social
whatever else you want to throw in there
they're not doing anything disruptive to
the industry and there needs to be a
disruptive influence for it to take have
any hold like tick tock was did a new
thing whether you like it or not yeah no
exactly and what a lot of conservatives
have been saying is we need conservative
social media platforms that's not true
we need social media platforms that
everyone wants to use but which also
won't ban conservatives and so they sort
of market themselves and it might be
cynical they might understand they're
actually selling a niche product to
people by giving them the hope that
it'll turn into something more but
ultimately it just gets filled with
conservatives regular people who don't
have any kind of political bench or
people on the left are still using
twitter or instagram and it doesn't
really get us anywhere also i don't
think these other social media
alternatives are actually free speech
platforms like they claim to be i think
it was gab but there's a couple of other
like twitter wannabes who do have a
direction they're not i'm not a free
speech absolutist you can't have every
single thing on your feed all the time
the gore the
other stuff that we don't need to get
into but these they they call themselves
free speech but they're something
different so everybody has their own
version of what they want to call free
speech and gab is as close as you can
get but even they don't allow doxing i
agree with that but you know we had
torber here and he was like
nobody likes that you know what i mean
weren't you not even allowed to talk
trash about something i forgot no exact
examples but kind of wild gab
you know their policy is if the first
amendment allows it and then i said yeah
but the first amendment does allow
doxing and he's like well there is an
exception now that's still an
interesting point because there was a
great conversation that happened to
tucker carlson a couple years ago where
someone said you know tucker was talking
about censorship and free speech and
hate speech and they said tucker would
you allow someone on your show to say a
bunch of racial slurs and he was like no
of course not he's like exactly because
you have policies for your platform
now the issue there is while i agree
we don't like racists
fox news tucker carlson's show is his
show where he has a space for one guest
to come and sit down and of course he
can curate that twitter is claiming to
be this open public forum that has
actually taken over the town center in
that case
yeah we shouldn't all be just the
arbiters of truth and morality
determining who is or isn't how to speak
don't kill those oh
but you want it you want to grab it and
just not crush it that one it's too late
for that one yeah well no no i'm saying
if you squish it it stinks there's
things okay so just ball it up and throw
the trash i'll be right back guys you
got to give the warning about the stink
bugs oh yeah yeah when you crush them
i thought you should just let them climb
on king kong yeah ruthless i'm hawkish i
was taking that buck out yeah but stink
bugs are clumping bomb that's the stink
bugs don't do anything they're funny
they're just stupid yeah they're just
stink i'm just anti bug
usually we just watch them do their
thing because stink bugs are everywhere
i was i was actually sort of distracted
i saw a couple of you guys looking and i
was like i'm going to take it out
it's a big mistake i saw these swords
around too i got a little bit excited i
think you don't have any firearms or i
was walking through the through the
hallway in here and a stinkbug was on
the wall and saw me and what the stink
bugs do as a defensive move is just
kamikaze they just jump to the floor and
so i'm walking and just like falls in
the here go and i'm just like this
stupid thing
we were talking about something
important yeah what was the last thing
you said sorry i got something i i do
think though that i mean
we're talking about uh trump and trump
being on platforms and twitter says they
have no plans to put him back on but
that doesn't mean they won't yeah at
some point can you imagine if trump was
back on twitter it would be really a lot
of fun would be hitting his life alert
like
oh my goodness
his life alert
what a fantastic day that would be could
you imagine if we got to see him
tweeting throughout this presidency did
you see what would be great would be
trump replying to biden's stupid things
like biden's video last week where he
told all american parents to affirm
their kids and gender transition
and it's just like what are you what do
you say like you don't know what that
means the the devil well when i was this
is a true story when i was a little kid
i told my mom i wanted to be a pumpkin
nice
i'm not saying she said you are my
little pumpkin no
is like actually a true story i was like
a little kid my mom would be like he
says he wants to be a pumpkin and it's
like yeah i was a little kid could you
imagine if they were like well all right
i guess and then just like started
that's my question is like put a pumpkin
over my body why is it only gender we're
supposed to affirm
you know why aren't we supposed to
affirm dinosaurs or dogs or when the kid
walks around thinking that they're a cat
or a robot my son for a while thought
maybe he was a robot i have another
that's a deeper person what about a
superhero like why are we not affirming
kids who think they're superheroes and
believe they can fly why aren't we
affirming those kids they can just jump
out
i do have a true story of the dangers of
this kind of affirmation when i was a
little kid there was a nintendo game
called mighty bomb jack and so i took a
plastic shopping bag and put it over my
arms like a cake and started jumping on
the bed yelling mighty bomb jack and i
fell and i banged my leg on the bed post
i started screaming and uh almost
seriously hurt myself if only see my
parents they affirmed me they know i
have a similar i'm kidding they didn't
actually this true story when i was a
little kid yeah when i was listening is
it a firm or maybe a little bit of
neglect no it wasn't like it was good
for a kid a little kid was running
around doing dumb kid things right look
i think that's a good thing i had a buzz
lightyear costume and i jumped off my
couch attempting to fly when i was like
two or three and broke my ankle so you
do really similar instances yes yeah
good work everyone well i i thought i
could be a ballerina and so i got signed
up for ballet lessons and during a
recital i fell off a stage oh my
goodness clearly should have kept me
home no that is like you don't identify
that's good affirmation your parents
should encourage you to do
arts and sports and stuff yeah what they
should encourage you to do is like i
don't know take chemicals that
permanently alter your body when you're
too young um
they shouldn't kill their grandchildren
before you've even had your first sexual
experience well i think i think it's
particularly simple it's um you wouldn't
give a little girl breast implants to
affirm her sexuality you wouldn't give a
little boy breast implants either i
don't understand why they're gonna my
son once asked me uh what i would say if
he told me he wanted to wear nail polish
to school and i told him that i would
say absolutely not and i and then i was
like and ask me what i would say if you
were a girl and he and i was like you
would also not be allowed to wear nail
polish to school i don't care what your
sex is there's no nail polish in school
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you